MaMartine, Michel, Paul, bonsoi.
LeLe cabinet du ministre
clclairement en référence à cete
hihistoire des adolescents qui
dedepuis neuf mois d'or sur le
plplancher du gymnase à Rouyn-
NoNoranda, ils nous dit qui vont
réréintégrer leur chambre d'ici
vevendredi.
CÇa vient de tomber, alors
apapparemment que Quebecor n'étt
ababsolument pas au courant de
cecela.
AuAutre histoire qui a fait
réréagir, l'histoire de CHSLD
HeHerron, un courriel qu'un
jojournaliste à débusquer, je vs
momontrais des petites parties u
cocourriel :
onon finit en nous disant que
c'c'est très problématique, donc
dedes lumières se sont allumées.
LaLa sous-ministre qui parlent e
miministre, ma question, est-ce
ququ'il y avait assez d'indices
popour sonner la cloche général?
- - D'abord, c'est pas blanc ou
nonoir, il y a plusieurs zones
grgrises il y a un délai de 10
jojours entre ce courriel et la
pupublication de l'histoire des
rurun qui nous a tous fait
susursauter, qui est un moment
pipivot dans la pandémique en
cecette histoire est publié dans
lala gazette sur les CHSLD Herr.
QuQuand le premier ministre dit
auaujourd'hui que si on avait s,
c'c'est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
lalaissé cela aller, je pense
ququ'on peut le croire.
AuAu moment où le courriel arrie
avavec la mention urgence, on et
totoujours 18, dononc on commenà
prprendre connaissance de
l'l'ampleur de mes qu'il ne se
sosoit pas passé de suivi entree
momoment où on est informé et la
pupublication de l'histoire, c't
unun peu surpris El.
CÇa pète de partout.
IlIl y a de plus en plus de CHSD
avavec des explosions et c'est
vrvraiment très étonnant qu'on t
totous mis cela dans les mains u
CICIUSSS.
- - On a l'air écoutera pas
l'l'opposition, on va tout de
susuite aller à l'extrait de
l'l'ministre du premier ministre
LeLegault.
MAMARGUERITE BLAIS, ministre
reresponsable des Aînés , Québec
- - Je n'ai pas à être sur
lala défensive. J'ai fait tout
cece que j'étais capable de fai.
QuQuand un établissement
nonous dit qu'il prend en charge
unun CHSLD privé, on le croit.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - On disait : "Le CIUSSS
dede l'Ouest-de-l'Île prend
enen charge la situation
dadans le CHSLD Herron."
C'C'est ce qu'on dit
dadans le courriel,
dodonc c'était rassurant.
SiSincèrement, là, est-ce
ququ'il y a quelqu'un qui pense
quque, si Danielle McCann,
MaMarguerite Blais ou moi,
onon avait été au courant
dede ce qui se passait de
teterrible dans le CHSLD Herron,
ququ'on n'aurait rien fait?
- - Bon, voilà la défense!
PaPaul, est-ce que ce courriel,
nonous ne sommes pas dans la
tataille des ministres qui l'ont
lulu, mais ce qu'il aurait dû
prproduire d'autres effets selon
vovous?
- - Il aurait dû avoir un suivie
totoute évidence il y a un
prproblème de communication.
CoComprend à l'époque ce n'était
papas le ce courriel est le seul
CHCHSLD où on commençait à
obobserver des problèmes très
crcritiques.
IlIl y a eu un suivi dans le ses
ouoù l'établissement a décidé de
prprendre le relais.
LeLe problème c'est l'étape
susuivante, est-ce qu'il y a eu
unune communication adéquate ene
lele CHSLD, le CIUSSS et le
miministère?
LaLa réponse est non parce que
sisinon ça voudrait dire que le
gogouvernement savait et n'a rin
fafait.
JeJe pense que le problème c'est
dede comprendre où la
cocommunication a été brisée eta
reresponsabilité politique elle
esest soit à la ministre, la
reresponsabilité politique, mais
j'j'ai hâte de voir le rapport e
lala CoronaVac pour savoir quel
momoment n'a pas communiqué pare
quque si grave que les formatios
nene se soient pas rendues à
tetemps.
- - Comme vous dîtes en attraità
dede lire ce rapport.
OnOn nous disait que c'était ici
lala fin du printemps.
PoPour les masques, tour de tab,
nonous avons perdu Michel, maise
n'n'est pas nouvelle mesure, ily
a a une question de prudence les
gegens se disent pourquoi pas?
- - Surtout que quand on avait
anannoncé que la fin du Max ça
seserait pour le 15 avril, ça
méméritait un peu humain et note
inindex et nous nous étions dits
quque ce n'est pas la première u
lala troisième semaine d'avril t
onon ne savait pas où on n'en
seserait et c'est la moindre des
chchoses qu'on prolonge cette
memesure parce que si les
scscientifiques disent que c'est
lala chose à faire est la
memeilleure façon de combattre a
sisixième vague, c'est une chose
ququ'on ne veut pas ajouter des
memesures coercitives du jardi»"
ététablissement, mais vivre avec
lele virus ça veut dire de mieux
inintervenir dans les
ététablissements de santé, et
auaussi les gestes barrières coe
leles masques.
SiSi les experts disent que ça
aiaide à atténuer l'ampleur de a
sisixième vague, il me semble qe
leles coconséquences et les
irirritants pour la population e
soson pasmal.
- - Michel vous est à Paris, ma
ququestion est à propos du masq,
vovous apparaissez un autre mon,
ilil n'y a plus beaucoup de
mamasques autour de vous?
- - Je n'en vois presque pas saf
unun peu dans les transports en
cocommun.
CeCe n'est pas quelque chose de
gégénérale et ça fait un bout qe
cece n'est pas général, je me ss
fifié aux consignes officiellest
totout le monde regardait commen
exextraterrestre en se disant qe
nonous n'avions pas besoin de
fafaire cela ici.
AlAlors c'est vraiment un autre
momonde complètement.
CeCela dit, ils ont appliqué un
auautre système de mesures
sasanitaires simplement.
CÇa veut pas dire qu'il n'y a ps
dede contention ici et qu'ils
n'n'ont pas de crainte pour cete
sisixième vague.
- - Et Martine, il y a Éric
DuDuhaime, je vous montre son
twtweet d'hier qui disais que ls
Québécois seront les derniers à
dedevoir porter les masques.
, , Monsieur Duhaime va annoncer
dadans quelques minutes qu'il sa
cacandidat dans Chauveau, c'este
lului l'eau moulin pour lui?
- - Oui c'est cocasse comment ça
s's'est passé, nous ne sommes ps
totombés en bas de notre chaise,
MoMonsieur Legault nous l'avait
avaverti hier.
AuAujourd'hui comme savon publié
lele communiqué, nous n'avions s
mimis de date.
NoNous avons laissé le Docteur
BoBoileau dire que c'était d'ici
l'l'fin avril, mais nous avons
lalaissé des portes ouvertes por
lalaver la mesure plutôt si c'et
popossible.
OnOn avait un peu l'impression e
dadans son miroir au gouverneme,
ilil voyait Éric Duhaime
apapprocher, et effectivement, n
OnOntario et a Paris, il n'y a s
dede masques il y a seulement
l'l'Île-du-Prince-Édouard qui
anannoncé qui gardait le masque,
dodonc effectivement nous sommes
leles derniers.
- - Paul, connaissait bien Québ,
c'c'est un endroit Monsieur
DuDuhaime peut avoir du succès?
- - Tout à fait, je sais qu'en
202015, une élection partielle t
lala libérale l'avait emporté,
mamais vraiment c'est l'exceptin
ququi confirme la règle, le
gogouvernement Couillard venait
d'd'être élu et il est encore
popopulaire, les gens avaient eu
l'l'ouverture d'esprit de voulor
vovoter du côté du pouvoir, maià
lolong terme le vote est beaucop
plplus conservateur.
LaLa preuve c'est que l'ancien
chchef du Parti conservateur se
prprésentait là-bas.
- - Il avait réussi à se faire
élélire!
- - Gérard Deltell aussi.
- - Comment vous pouvez décrire
l'l'état d'esprit des troupeaux
auautour des Éric Duhaime?
OnOn a hâte au prochain sondage
imimagine?
- - Le caucus de Québec est très
nenerveux et on le sent.
IlIl semble que Monsieur Duhaime
leleur souffle dans le dos.
SiSix O.K. Monsieur Duhaime occe
unun terrain inoccupé au Québec,
lala droite, l'espace libre.
IlIl est très positionné sur
cecertains enjeux, on parlait ds
memesures sanitaires mais aussie
trtramway, sa position et ferme,
ilil est contre.
IlIl est talentueux et à
l'l'expérience, il était à l'ADQ
enen 2007 et c'est justement ce
ququ'il reproduit sur les mêmes
teterrains.
- - Michel C Auger, vous avez
paparlé de cela, Monsieur Legaut
a a dit qu'il allait remettre ls
clclés pour autoriser le tramwa,
mamais il faudra que les mères
prprouvent que les Québécois en
veveulent?
- - Oui ça veut dire le chaud et
lele froid donc oui il va
apapprouver, mais il doit lui
prprouver la plus populaire.
DoDonc j'aurais enenvie de lui
dedemander quelle est l'plus
gégénéral pour le REM, on peut s
didire au maire de nous prouver
l'l'acceptabilité sociale.
SiSi le gouvernement du Québec
dédécide qu'il ne veut plus pare
ququ'il n'aime pas ce qu'elle ma
fafait, il va sortir du projet,
mamais ce n'est pas juste de fae
unun sondage pour savoir si ça
mamarche, chacun a ses
reresponsabilités et là-dessus
c'c'est très clair, revenons à
MoMonsieur Duhaime, les députése
QuQuébec qui qui leur souffle de
lele cou et Monsieur Duhaime
dedemande un référendum pour le
trtramway, échange de position
mamais en même temps il nuit à
l'l'acceptabilité sociale.
MoMonsieur Duhaime fait part à a
CACAQ.
- - Est-ce que Monsieur Legault
prprend quand même position
dadavantage du maire pour ne pas
avavoir l'air contre les
trtransports en commun, contre s
GIGIEC, comment vous voyez ce qi
s's'est passé?
- - Je vois qu'il y a un
trtraitement de défaveur du
trtramway, le gouvernement
n'n'envoie pas ses projets à la
popopulation référendum, ne fait
papas la même chose pour le REMu
popour le troisième lien, il n'a
papas d'annonce qui dit qu'on aa
papas de troisième lien si on na
papas de majorité de gens en
fafaveur de on ne sait pas qui
popourra donner son opinion, de
ququelle façon et d'équivalent
vévérifié.
EtEt surtout pendant cette
cacampagne de sondages, on verra
leles mécanismes, gèrent devanta
poposition de Monsieur Legault t
dede son gouvernement.
AcAcceptabilité sociale je
cocomprends que c'est important,
mamais nous ne parlons pas de
scscientifiques qui essaient de
memesurer si l'acceptabilité
sosociale fonctionne, le
gogouvernement peut augmenter ou
didiminuer l'acceptabilité socie
enen fonction de son discours.
- - Il n'y avait pas d'accès étt
sosociale pour le métro de
MoMontréal, les commerçants
avavaient peur que ça leur enlèe
dede la clientèle.
- - Yanshu géopolitique très coé
enen ce moment parce que ce quee
gogouvernement essaie de faire s
dadames ni Monsieur Marchand à e
momouillé sur ce projet régiona.
IlIl lui dit qu'il peut faire ce
ququ'il veut mais qu'il y a des
gegens dans les banlieues qui
cocontribuent à l'essor économie
QuQuébec et qui veulent voyagert
ilil voudrait que le projet soit
rérégional.
EnEn même temps Monsieur Marchad
dodoit aussi entendre les Éric
DuDuhaime qui est contre, il n'a
papas vraiment le choix de dansr
avavec Monsieur Legault Silva
avavant son projet.
CÇa fait une chute politique
asassez tendue.
- - Si j'étais de mauvaise fois,
jeje ne le suis pas, mais je
rarappellerai que la démarche
c'c'est dire que c'est nous qui
fifinançons via l'ensemble de ds
cocontribuables, donc qui va se
prprononcer?
JeJe ne sais pas que ça devrait
êêtre l'ensemble du Québec, mais
onon voit que la logique du
gogouvernement..
- - si on élargit le cercle, tot
cecela s'inscrit dans une voloné
d'd'améliorer l'offre en transpt
enen commun.
PaPaul, vous avez fait un texte
inintéressant ce matin.
CoComment vous inscrivez ce qui
esest en train d'arriver à Québ?
C'C'est un bon exemple, il y a e
ststatu quo et de l'autre côté s
gegens qui veulent faire changer
leles choses.
- - Le rapport du GIEC qui a été
dédéposé hier à l'avantage de
momontrer des solutions concrèts
popour essayer de ralentir les
réréchauffement climatique.
UnUne des solutions c'est le
trtransport en commun et le lien
esest assez facile à faire.
LeLe gouvernement pourrait faire
lala promotion plus activement u
prprojet et de parler d'égalitét
papas seulement des désavantages
dede leur point de vue du projet
etet mettre l'accent davantage r
leles solutions, se termine
dadavantage sur le fait que le
gogouvernement a raison de dire
quque le position pas de cible
sasans jamais dire comment ils
vovont les atteindre, donc il ft
memettre l'accent sur les mesurs
etet non pas sur les objectifs
babasés sur pas grand-chose, mas
lele tramway est une mesure!
- - Ça fera parti de la prochaie
cacampagne, les réchauffement
clclimatique.
- - Chaque partie a émit ses
cicibles, Québec solidaire a paé
dede 55 %, et Monsieur Legault e
raradier qui leur avait des cibs
imimportantes mais qu'il ne leur
didise pas comment il s'y arriv,
c'c'est un peu la question!
PoPour atteindre des cibles de e
niniveau, c'est quand même assez
élélevé et le gouvernement, sa
cicible ces 37,5, est-ce que la
QuQuébec solidaire va demander
d'd'péage sur les ponts?
NoNous n'avons pas d'idées!
- - Michel, on va se reparler ds
prprix essentiels à Paris, macrà
chchaud?
- - Oui premier tour, macro à 27
etet Marine Le Pen 21.
LeLes grands plateaux français,l
y y en avait avec toutes candids
àà la présidence et le seul qui
nene sait pas présenter ses
mama